that is pretty dead-on pretty much the  same size how do you feel about that  presidential you're handing me larger or  smaller like I I'm gonna be so  disappointed if my hands are smaller the  Donald Trump smaller I think my hands  gonna crush his um I would like them to  be larger I don't know I think I think  bigger  uh it's gonna be I'm gonna be proud of  all feel god I hope so  I'm scared to be smaller that I have  like smaller hands for a person my my  height oh yeah crush them it's really  creative okay definitely larger  definitely all right go for it oh really  flexing my fingers here okay close the  same size okay well oh yeah whoa oh God  child hands  what does he hold a pen with you alright  should we find out yeah how tall is he  at six - not yeah I mean I have small  hands for a dude they're fast  drinks to the defender  Oh